everything's complicated but there's
always a solution
[Music]
gotta go oh hey
how was work it was good what are you
reading
[Music]
so you figure out where you're gonna
apply yet don't know
josh and i are still talking about it so
that's still the plan
follow josh to school you and mom were
teenage sweethearts
and don't say you had a bond fargo
you want me to say we had a bond yes i
do
we had a bond
everything's complicated but there's
always a solution
seen that car before from the bank
those people aren't from the bank hang
on
[Music]
right now we need to go they found us
we're gonna get somewhere safe so long
america
have a nice day what did he do
i'm sorry
[Music]
pack one bag be ready in 10 minutes
how much trouble are you actually in no
not everything can be fixed
of course you can the trick is actually
wanting to fix it
none of us likes this situation
unless we do the right thing here it
will escalate
what's about to happen might seem like
imperfect parenting
this is gonna be an adventure
a bunch of fugitives are heading south
of mexico
i had plans go to school get a life
i can't just hide out with you guys
forever
what do you do it's difficult to explain
i'm interested in you if you are
could i believe you to be
[Music]
i don't think we feel very comfortable
having this conversation
why are you doing the stem
[Music]
why is he doing this to you tina
where are you guys headed
[Music]
you